[Music]
is joe Jonas's new tattoo a tribute to
his fiance sophie Turner
[Music]
here's the photo the dnce frontman
instagrammed on sunday showing off his
new ink that features the outline of a
mysterious naked woman with the caption
at kurt montgomery tattoos does it again
the knot right above is a tattoo he
reportedly got in honor of his family in
2012 you know the connection we have as
a family still is is really unique fans
took to the comment section of Joe's
post speculating that the new design
must be a nod to his 22-year old fiancee
sophie turner one fan even drew a
correlation between the redline and
Sophie's red hair meanwhile it seems the
actress also got a new tattoo from the
very same artist she captioned this
photo of what appears to be the outline
of a rabbit quote by the hero and my
fave at Kurt Montgomery tattoos Joe and
Sophie announced their engagement back
in October but have remained pretty
tight-lipped about any wedding deeds the
one thing we do know Sophie's Game of
Thrones co-star Maisie Williams will be
one of her bridesmaids
[Music]